one thing nearly did trump in and hurt
him in Wisconsin was when he's asked on
a question that you know as a Kennedy
and Republican Party gonna get an
abortion the shock wasn't particularly
although he got in trouble with that he
wasn't prepared for it
hi I'm Nicolas we with reason TV we are
at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas Nevada and
we are talking to Steve Forbes a man who
needs no introduction Steve thanks for
talking to us
good to be with you you have come out as
a pro Trump supporter what is it about
Trump that you're getting behind well I
said first of all I'd support the
Republican nominee and so I didn't
endorse anyone until he gets the
official nomination and you're still
hoping that something will happen
well go get lost driving to Cleveland
I've made it very clear I disagree with
them on immigration we're not going to
deport 11 million people and on tariffs
45% taxes it's a 45 percent sales tax
would be a disaster but the key thing is
there's so of those things I do disagree
with sadly the other side the big other
side we'll see if gary johnson can
emerge but on the Democrat side they're
just as bad she's gone Hillary Clinton's
gone a socialist light Bernie and
they've both learned you don't say
socialist you say social that sounds
like you're friendly a social but it's
it's the same thing more and more state
control Trump's tax plan especially now
that steve moore and larry cudlow are
working on the thing should be a more
pro-growth and Paul Ryan in the house
wants big tax reform I think what
they're going to find if zooming Trump
wins that on the tax side Trump does not
have much emotional and energy invested
in it so if you come up with something
he'll sign it Trump has a you know
particular persona as a presidential
candidate does that differ you you've
known Donald Trump since the 80s how is
he when he's not on the kind of
presidential chicken circuit he can be
very charming when he's in negotiations
about something that he cares about but
he also knows how to play in
one person good cop bad cop one minute
your friend next minute he's going to
hit you hard and so that's what makes
them effective of the negotiating table
with us he's always debating our
estimation of his wealth and just one
story on it we related and Forbes
magazine back last fall so our editor
goes up to his office in Trump Tower the
day the Pope is in New York and so they
hear the hubbub outside there's a
balcony apparently so they went out on
the balcony a lot of Latinos with the
Pope from Argentina and so there are
some cheers for Trump but a lot of boos
he turns to redditor and says you see
90% approval and then he says this shows
you've underestimated the value of this
building because the Pope chose my
building to begin his parade in New York
City so another so this is a man who
just tries to bend the world to the way
he I was gonna say this sounds like a
man who was deeply delusional no it was
Steve Jobs and we pointed this out in
the story doesn't cut both ways was the
same thing he had a vision for a product
and he would just bend until it came
about and where that goes that absolute
will goes is very very interesting do
you worry I mean Trump has you worried
about anyone who gets that office well
and one who hasn't you know Reagan was
unaffected
if you didn't realize it prepping for
for the office he eventually occupied
and in Trump's case there's a lot of
unknowns and he's gotten a lot of issues
where he realized you just can't be off
the cuff on it you've got her there's a
reason why they have teleprompters to
make sure you stay on message well
beaking what what I was going to ask
about is Trump has said you know he's
effectively threatened the Free Press
he's talked about opening up the libel
laws he's talked about going after the
New York Times when they write false
things about him obviously thinks Forbes
is full of it when they're estimating
his wealth so I mean do you worry about
that at all as a media person
well the question is one thing when
you're not having a high office and you
get angry about something I was a PC you
know what I wish I could smack them
around and quite another when
everything you say is weighed and will
be held against you and so one of the
things he has to reassure people on is I
can get real things done I've know how
to put teams together buildings just
don't rise up by themselves you've got
to have a lot of cooperation make things
happen and I can do the same thing in
Washington so people will say doubts
about the guy but maybe we can take it
but you're not worried that he will
actively try and harness the press or
actually take it to a next level you're
not just combating it but in trying to
pass he did the press would not show the
same reticence with him that they did
constantly with Barack Obama no get out
of jail free card for Trump or anybody
else maybe Clinton but not for a
Republican they will be all over them
the way you say but the way they should
be I'm gonna open up our libel laws so
when they write purposely negative and
horrible and false articles we can sue
them and win lots of money obviously
Hillary you you line up everything in
the no column Trump many things in the
no column but he is more pliable really
by a Republican Party that maintains I'm
sorry I think gun on the tax side what
they're gonna find is what happened in
86 when the Democrats wanted to do with
tax shelters Republicans wanted to bring
rates down and they found out that if
you touch one tax shelter you have to
hit all of them you just can't pick and
choose so this idea that we'll leave in
a couple of deductions the two Biggie's
for home mortgages and charity and the
rest we can tamper with
they're gonna find either do it or you
don't so I think we get one of those
rare instances this after all be 30
years since 1986 where you end up
getting more than you anticipated when
you started the process instead of less
one of the things during the during the
Republican campaign primary campaign you
were critical of Republican candidates
the serious ones not really bringing
things forward that with this this this
is where it's amazing
you had Trump at 16 others
he came up with a slogan well we would
and what did the others have a slogan
for zero so they so they were seen as
bland and these are people many of them
who made their living in the political
world but couldn't seem whatnot what
were they were they part of our part of
the problem is yes some of them are very
nice or interesting proposals but they
never led with them they never related
him in a way what you might call a take
away for for individuals with George
Bush he said I want four percent GDP
growth I knew what he or said Jeb Bush
Jeb join one four percent GDP growth
well I understood what he was saying but
most people four percent GDP sounds like
a hair formula
you know Rogaine four percent GDP oh yes
and so they never related in a way where
people said okay I can see how this can
improve my lot in life improved the
country the way Reagan did in 1980 when
he advocated a 30 percent
across-the-board cut in income tax rates
the Democrats of course ridiculed
economists were skeptical and
Republicans had their doubts but he got
the national mandate and got most of it
done they didn't do it here and so you
know I almost have fantasized sometimes
for five minutes bringing back Josef
Stalin to shoot all the consultants and
then go back to hell why did miss you
why didn't you step into the ring as
somebody who is a recidivist
presidential candidate well you know
this seems like this would be your time
well with 16 others I thought that the
pressure of competition being a believer
in free markets you know the states
could make a good case the GOP is an
example of free markets don't work and
and just as when you look at presidents
since Reagan you could say that's a good
argument against evolution but in the
case of the GOP so I'd run twice and now
so my role now is an agitator so we had
with a group like Kudlow and Steve Morin
art Laffer we had dinners with other
people with these various candidates to
give pride more learn more try to get
them more on line with the Pro free
markets in terms of taxes and money
so we thought this would be the year in
which it would happen but they all read
from the same playbook and what's
amazing is that when Trump rose up put
aside his prescriptions at least he's
put something on the table they didn't
point anything real on the table
advocating it up front give you one
example on health care burning issue is
what drove people in 2010 drove people
in 2014 and yet none of them led with
things like how about posting prices for
hospitals and clinics basic stuff that
people would say yes that would be great
and relating it in a way that people
could understand they didn't do it and
so he can't fight something with nothing
talk about one of your other I mean you
talk a lot about health care and about
bringing actual market forces and at
least market signals into into health
care another obsession of yours is the
Fed what what is the what is the role of
the Fed currently and in the sluggish
economy well but they're trying to
control the US economy through
manipulating interest rates and buying a
lot of bonds I guess they hadn't gotten
the word yet I know the era of fast
communications they should have gotten
it by now
the Berlin Wall fell in 1989 the Soviet
Union collapsed in 1991 but they think
it can guide the economy through a
central bank with a handful of mandarins
central planning doesn't work and what
they've done in terms of controlling the
price of money control between lenders
and borrowers instead of letting them
set what what the rest would what
interest rates be much higher or how but
they would be different but at least the
market could work remember when they
controlled gasoline prices you had lines
of literally miles long and when they
when Reagan did away with price controls
yes prices actually went down but even
when they went up you didn't have lines
and so what you have today with the
distorted credit market is corporations
no problem borrowing money bonds are for
big established companies no problem for
government borrowing money but for small
businesses and house
holds and remember small and new
businesses are how you get the dynamism
in the economy and the big companies of
tomorrow
they've been starved a credit that and
they're hardly grown at all when in a
recovery that should be booming so the
good and you say you have X on borrowing
twelve billion what do they borrow
twelve billion to buy in their stock not
the best use of capital Apple two
hundred and thirty billion dollars and
cash and securities around the world
borrowing over tens of billions of
dollars a bunch why cuz they can it's so
cheap they can buy the issue the bonds
and buying their stock and have a spread
on the yield of the bonds and and then
the dividend financial engineering talk
you know you you've been mentioned as a
final comment you've mentioned Reagan
quite a bit what is the what is the what
is your vision of the future it's not
simply going back to Reagan policies is
it or like what Reagan what do we need
different well Reagan understood first
he's one of the rare individuals who
could lead a movement but also have
success in the political world where
nothing ever goes straight but he got
some big things done and so it's not
going back it's going forward with basic
principles that we know work and this is
what surprised me in this campaign the
problem with health care is not the
quality we have in this country if you
have cancer which I had several years
ago you want to be here you don't want
to be in England or anywhere else the
problem is we don't have real free
markets and the proof of it is I like to
point out is no crummy even the crummy
motel in America wouldn't dare put you
in a room with another guest with a
curtain in between a sick person they
routinely do that in hospitals I talked
with a fellow the other day they talked
about expanding a hospital in though I
think was in Vermont and they had single
private rooms it's not just to make the
patient feel better but help fight
infections and basic things like that
are you optimistic about the future yes
because when something doesn't work at
least in this country we get it we
demand a change sometimes it takes a
while to get it back in the 1970s that's
how Carter got elected in 70s ago this
might be just didn't work so then we got
Reagan in 1980 that did work and so I
think the this time if
assuming Trump wins if he doesn't work
we'll get we'll get another one in 2020
if she's in we know it won't work so
we'll get something else in 2020 and in
terms of Gary Johnson and Bill weld and
the libertarian side they've got to get
their act together they've got to get
real themes out there not just sort of
passive things I'd like to do this and
maybe something that they got to go
vigorously forward make the case and
when they go on to things like CNN a
town hall they are ready with themes
messages to get across answers
anticipate questions one things that
nearly did Trump in and hurt him in
Wisconsin was when he's asked on a
question that you know is a Kennedy and
Republican party you're gonna get an
abortion the shock wasn't particularly
answer although he got in trouble with
that he wasn't prepared for it you
believe in punishment for abortion yes
or no as a principle the answer is that
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah there has to be some
form that I don't know frankly I do take
positions and everything else it's a
very complicated position and that's if
Johnson and well want to make a
breakthrough they're gonna have to have
that down they've got to be preparing
now for the big time they've been
accustomed to playing double-a ball and
we're now going in the major leagues and
they don't have the luxury of having
months as a normal candidate would do to
try things get things going get your act
together like a boxer getting ready for
a match you just don't go in the ring
you've had a lot of prep time if they
want to make the breakthrough and get
that 15 percent in the polls so they can
go in the debates they got to get those
themes out there and relate it to where
individuals can say AHA that's the key
to success when the voter says AHA I get
where this might help all right we will
leave it there thank you so much thank
you for reason TV I'm Nikolas me